[Music]
what do you make of cardi B and Nicki
Minaj party is that girl I don't know
the other one party is my girl that was
little Kim throwing shade at Nicki Minaj
when et chatted with her back in June
and we won't mention one female we need
to mention them all now the legendary
rappers seemingly wants to put the drama
to rest addressing her ongoing feud with
Minaj head-on in a radio interview with
real 92.3 best I'm past them over it I'm
Specter like at the end of the day no
this is gonna sting stop asking me about
respect I love you you cool you always
been cooling but she did what she did
and until she's ready to be you know
hopefully God puts it on her mind or
whoever else do the right thing because
she knows she did and once that happens
then you know hopefully everyone was
that Kim's beef with Minaj dates back to
2011 when she released Black Friday
during Minaj's pink friday debut album
release week so remember what you said
when you think about situations what
have I always done
you've always embraced Ewing orders so
now those questions to stop
as for whether Kim known as the original
Queen V cares about Nikki or any other
artist giving themselves the title queen
she had this to say can't work Queen and
I don't really care about it either I
was named that I never named myself it's
a difference when the streets name you
that right biggie named me that I named
my stuff first person you got to name
yourself that's a whole different thing
I don't I would never name myself day
[Music]
[Applause]